Crowd: GOOD MORNING, JOHN!!!!
Hank: Theoretically, a bunch of people just said good morning to you,
but that has not happened to me yet,
because it is five in the morning,
and I have to get on a plane....
There was a guy....that whole time I was talking....
he was very quiet.
Did you know, John, that planes have a kind of a butt hole?
The majority of the exhaust on a plane comes out through the engines,
but there is also a thing called the auxiliary power unit,
which powers all of the electronics on the plane
like everything from the crackling speakers to the hydraulics to the vacuum-powered poop pump thingy
and it vents out its exhaust through a port that is called, in my head,
the planus.
That was the punchline.  That's why I told the whole story.
Yep.  It's all true, though.
Is it weird that Jean Luc Picard doesn't have hair?
Shouldn't they have cured balding by the 24th century?
Did you know....that fish don't fart?
This is...this might not sound that weird, but it's actually really weird.
There are some fish that use gas internally as ballast...
most of them burp that up,
uh, when they need to get rid of some air, but
some of them do...have it come out the other end.
But as far as, like, bacterial gas produced in the gut of fish,
it doesn't come out of them.  It is produced though
cause they have the same kind of gas producing organisms in their gut that we do.
It is a mystery...where that gas goes!
That's a weird thing for us to not know!
(sleepily) In addition to being exhausted, I'm also bursting with excitement internally...
*music in background* Super.....that's quite a dance song....
Really just, uh, quite happy
that, uh, at least 55% of the Supreme Court of the United States,
uh, is not crazy!
It's nice to see that Canadian currency has made a bit of a come back
and the only difference between it and American currency now apparently
is that Canadians realize that 30 bucks and 29.95 are the same freakin' thing.
Eeeehhh and whenever you're going to Portland, everybody always says,
"Don't forget your Wii!"
Been dropped off at a loading dock
I don't know what I'm doing
or....what...I should do now.
I think I just met someone who's even more tired than me!
It's Devon Murray!
Devon: "Hey, how's it going?"
Hank: "How are you doin'?
Devon: "Not too badly...a little bit worse for wear with all the flyin' but then again there..."
Hank: "This is a terrible thing to say, but I keep expecting him to light something on fire."
Hank:"Tell me the story that you just told me."
Devon: "I just blew my microwave up the other day...
I was, eh, upstairs - and all of a sudden - havin' a shower, I come back downstairs.  There's smoke all over the house.
It was only a brand new microwave.
So..first time being used I should have watched it.
Hank: "That doesn't sound like it was your fault."
Devon: "Oh no, of course it wasn't."
Hank: "Okay."
Devon: "But still...hashtag, eh, Seamus."
*Hank laughs*
Devon: "That's it."
*chorus of hello's*
Hank: "So it turns out that the cast of the Lizzie Bennett Diaries just breaks out into song pretty frequently."
(person 1 singing) Portland...
(person 2 singing)...watcha doin' Portland?
(person 1 singing) So many people I never knew in Portland.
(person 2 singing) .....portland...
I'm about to go on stage with Lauren Fairweather
wearing my Lauren Fairweather shirt.
Insert crowd screaming now!
*crowd screaming*
That's why I'm happy to get up early in the morning to do this kind of stuff
because that is better than any amount of sleep possible.
John -
Crowd: " - I'll see you on Tuesday!"
But of course I was wrong when I said that
I won't see John on Tuesday
I will see Rosie on Tuesday.
I am very tired.
I am going....to go.
To bed.
Yay pillowwssss!
I'm so happy about this bed!!